well the the thing that we're not
thinking about i think
is just how you know payment processors
etc you know
exactly is how truly unstable the entire
online ecosystem is right
uh you mentioned payment processors uh
there's there's
sort of you know uh the domain
registration services that's that's a
big question
uh there are sort of you know cdn
services
that's a big question mark that i have
you know if you get really far down the
line
and the tech companies feel
extraordinarily powerful do you get to a
point where
if you type in a website on a mobile
browser the browser won't actually
resolve like that's sort of a hallmark
of a free and open internet
is that if you type in a website you go
to that website
do the browsers themselves start
becoming agents of censorship
you also have a vc firm and and you're
actually
getting in the fight right now by uh by
getting involved with rumble can you
talk about that a little bit
yeah that's right yeah so so we launched
our vc firm in cincinnati
you know i'd been in vc the industry for
a few years i always wanted to do
something in my hometown
so we launched it as a cincinnati-based
firm in 2019
you know myself a partner and a couple
of our employees who are who are great
and you know we we like on the one hand
we're just a classic vc firm right we
try to invest in really good companies
and help them grow
you know one of the companies i'm most
proud of that we invested in is a
company called app harvest
which is an agriculture technology
company in eastern kentucky
now has a close to 2 billion market cap
and when we invested it was it was
really just in its formative stages
um so a lot of good stuff happening but
yeah one of the companies i'm most proud
that we got involved with was rumble
and uh you know i know you know a lot
about rumble but the thinking there was
actually
you know we were sort of looking at a
lot of the alternative tech
platforms in the wake of january the
sixth right it's like okay this is
pretty scary the president united states
just got booted off of social media
maybe these companies are too powerful
you know let's look at gab let's look at
parlor let's look at a lot of the
companies that are out there
that are actually providing something
like free speech to people who want to
live in the digital world
and you know liked a lot of the
companies that we looked at couldn't
quite get comfortable that they were
actually robust enough technology to
withstand
you know what eventually the platforming
incident that came against parlor that
effectively shut the site down for a
couple of months
um and so but just kept on looking and
we finally met chris
who's the the ceo and the founder of
rumble who i know you know well
um and and started like talking to chris
and thinking okay so so you know first
of all their user metric numbers are
incredible they're growing at a really
remarkable clip
they've never had an infusion of capital
so they've sort of done all of this
growth organically
but also chris had built the platform
you know not to be like a conservative
website or a liberal website
but just to be a true alternative
website like the technology was robust
you know we felt like well if aws tries
to de-platform this company they're not
going to be able to be successful
because of the way that chris had built
the underlying technology and so just
eventually got really excited about what
they were doing
made a big investment there you know
brought peter thiel along into the deal
he also made a big investment in the
company
and now it's just it's growing at a
really amazing clip and we think that
this could be
a true independent a political
alternative to big tech
right so i don't want to say too much at
the moment but i am having dinner
in miami with chris on friday so i'll
leave that part there but in essence
is is the goal that you guys sort of
want to replace aws
that you guys would basically say hey
we've got all of the infrastructure
chris is an engineer he's been building
this thing for 10 years like we've got
the infrastructure so that
you won't just be blown up like parlor
because you're right that was the moment
where it was like everyone realized this
thing just the the the
severity of the situation just went
through the roof
that's right yeah more even than trump
being the platform parlor being
effectively kicked off the internet was
really radicalizing
you know to me and to a lot of other
people as well you know
certainly one of the options i'll put it
this way one of the options i think for
rumble is to become
a long-term apolitical true free speech
aws
right the the sort of online web
platform that's not going to de-platform
you because you say things that the mob
doesn't like but one of the things i've
learned working in the technology sector
is you always try to have a good plan
and you execute against it
but there are a lot of forks in the road
and i think rumble
you know has 10 different pathways to
the moon
like this is not a company that just has
one real
option to go after and what i think
actually what what you know there's
always challenges with companies and one
of the challenges with rumble that i
think about
is they have such a big market
opportunity they have so much they could
do
that i think focusing and picking the
right strategic pathway
is almost going to be the biggest
challenge because uh the company again
they're just doing really well and
they've got a lot of real upside
right and not to do too much of a
commercial here but you guys had
you guys had the trump rally a couple
days ago live streamed on rumble over
000 people i think biden's speech
yesterday or the day before 18 000
people on youtube so
so something good is going on over there
yeah that's exactly right 500
000 people and being able to handle that
amount of traffic as a new company
is is not easy so we were really pleased
with it
yeah so as this ecosystem kind of
kind of comes together are there other
pieces that you think
uh we need to be thinking about that
maybe we're not thinking about
well the the thing that we're not
thinking about i think
is just how you know payment processors
etc
exactly is how truly unstable the entire
online ecosystem is right
uh you mentioned payment processors uh
there's there's sort of you know
uh the domain registration services
that's that's a big question
uh there are sort of you know cdn
services
that's a big question mark that i have
you know if you get really far down the
line
and the tech companies feel
extraordinarily powerful do you get to a
point where
if you type in a website on a mobile
browser the browser won't
actually resolve like that's sort of a
hallmark of a free and open internet
is that if you type in a website you go
to that website
do the browsers themselves start
becoming agents of censorship
so what's crazy about the internet i
mean is that there are probably you know
40 or 50 really critical layers that
make it work from sort of payments
processing
front-end services all the way down to
the the back-end stuff that 99
of people don't see or care about but at
each level
there are only a few companies that
actually control things right
and so it's not inconceivable that you
have an
internet where people can't have access
to it if they're not
sufficiently left-wing that's sort of a
big concern that i have
and i and i think that there are a lot
of good folks you know
a lot of good firms that are working on
ensuring there are alternatives that are
truly committed to free speech uh so i'm
you know
i'm somewhat optimistic that some of
these alternatives are coming online
but i do in some way see this as like a
race against the future
because the left is as you know is not
becoming less crazy it's actually
becoming more crazy
and uh you know once they control the
information they really control the way
all of us think and that's pretty much
it
yeah is that part of the problem right
there that there's just sort of an
asymmetry
of who likes to use power i've been
talking about that a lot on the show
just that
we don't really want to use power even
in this conversation it's like ah you
know
competition government it's like we're
sort of okay with competing ideas being
out there
where when they have the power we know
what they do
yeah that's exactly right you know
people always ask me the difference
between left and right is it small
government big government
social conservative progressive what
what have you and i always say look the
big difference between the left and
right
is the left loves to use power and the
right is terrified of using power
and you know my my friend richard
hanania
is a really interesting thinker on this
he says the left loves to use power
because they actually care about
politics more
like you know you look at polling and
the right just doesn't care as much
about politics as the left does
i think unfortunately we're in an
environment where we have to get over it
because
if we're not willing to use power to
push back against the left i think that
power is going to come for us
it's going to come for our livelihood
it's going to come for our families it's
going to come eventually and already
started
coming for our very ability to speak and
to think for ourselves
and so i agree the left has a basic
instinctive advantage because they love
to use power
but we're just going to have to get over
it or we're going to find ourselves
without you know really
a real republic anymore yeah do you see
any sort of
version of of any of this ecosystem
where there has to be some regulations
around speech this is where the
gatekeeping conversation always comes in
you know are you gonna
let antifa coordinate on there on one
side versus
neo-nazis on another side or something
like that
you know obviously there's some there's
some regulation in every sphere and i
tend to think that you know look we've
had a first amendment in our country for
245 years and it's worked pretty well
uh and the basic outline of the first
amendment
is that you're allowed to speak your
mind you're allowed to say the things
that you want to say
so long as you effectively don't incite
violence against other people right
there are very
narrow limits on what you're allowed to
say but there are some limits
and i think that's fine uh and i think
that should be the hallmark to how we
think about the the regulation of speech
is you know we we should be open to
hearing and debate
um so long as it doesn't run afoul of
the basic principles of the first
amendment
now importantly like this doesn't you
know i think a lot of folks on the left
like to retreat and say well
you know are you not allowed to sort of
regulate a school curriculum for example
if you don't want to teach
four-year-olds
or eight-year-olds that they should hate
america and then america is a
fundamentally white supremacist country
uh is that like a violation of the first
amendment i think no no of course it
isn't right we've long
understood um that you know the way we
treat kids is different from the way we
treat adults and the purpose of our
schools is to form
people form young minds for future
leadership and
future citizenship so i think the first
amendment doesn't apply everywhere right
it applies to a 19 year old much
differently than it applies to a
three-year-old
but i think that should be our guiding
principle if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell